all right here's everything you need to
know that just got announced at Apple's
wonderlist event 2023. so first of all
the new iPhones iPhone 15 15 plus 15 Pro
and 15 Pro Max all these models have
matching Dynamic Island now which is
sick but they've all switched to USB
type-c finally goodbye lightning it's
crazy we knew this was coming but it's
still wild to see an iPhone in person
with USB you can now finally charge your
iPad your laptop and your iPhone and the
new airpods and your friend's Android
phone all with the same cable the pro
iPhones also now get a lighter stronger
titanium Rail and faster three nanometer
chip and there's some camera
improvements that we'll have to test
like every year and the pro Max also
gets the new 5x telephoto camera coolest
thing though in my opinion the mute
switch is gone from the pros and there's
a customizable action button instead and
it can do a bunch of stuff more than I
expected including muting your phone and
then we also got some new Apple watches
it's a series 9 and the ultra two they
both look exactly the same as last year
but there is a much improved faster chip
under the hood and they are allegedly
Apple's first completely carbon neutral
product there are way more details
though so get subscribed to make sure
you see the full video and the Hands-On
with the new iPhones